bonsoir la première chose à laquelle
j'ai pensé quand on a proposé de
remettre le césar du meilleur espoir
masculin
c'est pas une chose d'ailleurs c'est un
homme c'est à mathieu amalric jeune
fille jeune fille j'avais découpé une
photo de lui dans un télé poche que
j'avais collé au dessus de mon lit juste
à côté de celle de johnny depp et de
kurt cobain
quand il a reçu le césar du meilleur
espoir masculin
je me souviens hyper bien il est monté
sur scène il avait une veste noire avec
une travail bleue marine
je le trouvais magnifique et j'ai été
tellement ému que j'ai pas pu regarder
jusqu'au bout alors
alors à celui qui va aujourd'hui
recevoir le césar je voudrais dire ceci
vous n'êtes pas seuls
vous êtes sans doute déjà punaisé dans
la chambre d'une adolescente à côtés de
kanye west et de ryan gosling et quand
vous montrer sur scène elle sera avec
vous en pensez alors soyez en fiers et
ne la décevrais jamais car pour elle
vous êtes plus qu'un espoir
vous êtes un soleil